okay i want to give a sort of i guess
it's a shout out a kudos to some
democrats and one republican in one case
who had the balls to vote against some
of Donald Trump's cabinet picks the
Senate has now voted on for of trumps
major appointment nominees and has
confirmed all four on Inauguration Day
retired Marine Corps general james
mattis was confirmed 98 to one as
Secretary of Defense the same day he saw
another marine corps General John F
Kelly confirmed eighty eight to 11 as
Secretary of Homeland Security Monday US
Representative from Kansas and tea
partier Mike Pompeo was confirmed by
about a two-to-one vote 6632 is director
of the CIA and on Tuesday former South
Carolina Governor nikki Haley was
confirmed 96 24 as UN Ambassador
hearings are still going on there are
way more roll call votes set to happen
including the ones for jeff Sessions and
rex tillerson ben Carson Betsy DeVos but
let's take a look at the voting that has
taken place so far and look at which
Democratic senators have done the right
thing by voting no on Trump's pics and
which Democrats have fallen in line with
the nominees democrats who voted yes on
all four nominees here's the list Chuck
Schumer Tim Kaine Feinstein Schatz
Donnelly Klobuchar McCaskill Shaheen
Hassan hike camp read White House Warner
and joe Manchin from West Virginia the
only senator to vote against James
mattis was New York's junior senator
Democrat Kirsten Gillibrand and I
commend her for it there's also a bid
there's such a long list of incident
involving James Madison why he has no
place being there the silver lining is
he is against torture and has said that
to Donald Trump but lots of crazy stuff
and Madison's background for John F
Kelly 11 senators voted against his
appointment all Democrats and they made
the right move Kelly oversaw Guantanamo
he fought to keep it open he advocated
for force-feeding inmates there he did a
whole bunch of stuff that's absolutely
horrible
and those who voted against his
confirmation included Elizabeth Warren
Cory Booker camel Harris and Jeff
Merkley from Oregon then we had US
Representative Mike Pompeo as
confirmation which had the most
resistance 32 no votes even a Republican
voted no they're Rand Paul seemingly not
liking some of what Mike Pompeo said
they're Rand Paul D one Republican of
all of the nomination so far to bank a
no vote I mean it's kind of tricky
because you want to obstruct at the
right times so I don't know if I was a
senator which people I would vote for
which I wouldn't but certainly the
people like the Rick Perry's the Ben
Carson's the Betsy DeVos is who are just
ideologically opposed to the positions
they're going to take over yeah there's
no chance I would vote for them there
are some Democrats who voted no on three
of four Trump cabinet pics and i will
show you who they are number one Kirsten
Gillibrand from New York she voted no to
madis Kellyanne pompeo then we have
Martin Heinrich Martin Heinrich voted no
on Kelly pompeo and nikki Haley and then
we have Tom Udall who voted no on Kelly
pompeo and Haley voting YES on James
mattis they're doing something liberals
have been pressing Democrats to block
some of these nominees little effect sad
low energy but at least these Democrats
have done something to try to prevent
the insanity